[Musique]
te souviens du pont qu'on traverse un N
Guer pour passer la rivière tout près de
la maison le petit pont de bois qui ne
tenait plus guerre que par un grand
mystère et de piquet
droit le petit pont de bois qui ne
tenait plus guerre que par un grand
mystère et piquit tout
droit si tu reviens par là tu verras la
rivière j'ai refa en pierre le petit
pont de bois puis je l'ai recouvert de
rondin de bois vert pour rendre à la
rivière son vieillre d'autre
fois je l'ai recouvert de bois vert
rendre à la rivière son vire
[Musique]
d'autreis je l'ai recouvert r le bois
vert rendre à la rivière son vieillre
d'autre fois
elle suit depuis ce temps son cour
imaginaire car il ne pleut plus guerre
qu'une ou deux fois par an mais dans ce
coin de terre un petit pont bizarre
enambire au milieu des
foues mais dans ce coin de terre un
petit pont bizarre en jamb ÉU foir au
milieu
[Musique]
desouè nulle
part et pourtant j'en suis
[Musique]
fier merci beaucoup